japan is the home to some of the most  talented and well-known game creators  anywhere in the world  we're thrilled to be working with koei  tecmo to bring woe long fallen dynasty  to game pass  day one i'm also excited to be working  with team ninja it was a long history of  building incredible action games for  xbox and it's great to be working with  them once again  we know how important it is to our fans  to continue to bring more japanese  franchises to xbox  i'm excited to announce the return of  one of the most highly requested and  beloved franchises to xbox from our  partners at atlas  [Music]  [Music]  break away  [Music]  and you know we we're out there  [Music]  [Music]  bye